i am advocating to find your way
back to partnership the system may be
broken but the answer is is not to break
it more
it's like everyone's looking at the
system and saying well the dating system
is broken so now you've got to out
strategize that person you gotta pull
back you gotta do this you gotta
how about the system is broken let's fix
it let's find people who wanna fix it
let's invest within them let's stop
playing the game all together with
people who wanna play the game those
people will learn they're gonna be alone
a long time if nobody's willing to play
the game with you eventually you decide
not to play the game either right nobody
wants to play the game all alone you
ever sit at a board game try to play
with yourself
sorry bb after a while you're like
let me go do something else
when i say starve the beast i mean
starve what's ugly
build up what's good you don't have to
settle for garbage
just because there's a lot of garbage
that exists right now
no
make a decision not to entangle with
garbage and to do better you will be one
of many people think about if everybody
made that decision